tonight we're going to have a
presentation by Lauren Taylor Lauren is
an oral historian and psychiatric social
worker Sonia professor at the Columbia
University School of Social Work and
recently she served as a project
coordinator for the Harvard partnership
program on aging education Miss Taylor
has been on staff at Columbia since 1994
and has worked with the elderly
extensively and as a field adviser and
field instructor for Social Work
students who are internet at many
different agencies on aging from in 2002
2003 I'm sorry in conjunction with the
School of Social Work problems till they
made an educational film about sexuality
and aging funded by the Hartford
Foundation and distributed by the new
york academy of medicine in 2005 stila
created second film which brought
together young social worker students
and older women in a dialogue about
aging as an oral historian of this
pillar has conducted many many like
history interviews is going to talk a
little bit tonight about the
distinguishing features of psychiatric
social work interviews and the
interviews that she does is an oral
historian um yeah just a little related
note we have a wonderful experience here
tonight of really merging the
disciplines quite literally as we have
social work students and oral historians
in the same room so expecting a really
wonderful conversation and one more note
Miss Taylor and I actually were in
school together here with colleagues in
the oral history program and the real
finish before I did
and so it's a really double honor to be
here at a pleasure of one of the
wonderful stories and articles about
stories that Lauren shared with our
cohort was an article in Scientific
American about storytelling and about
the idea of myths that are present in
all of our lives and to be absolutely
need for storytelling is it just a human
drive at Lauren's going to speak a
little bit more about that tonight I
guess without any further ado in this
audience are not only all historians
students but also students from my human
sexuality class who are here because I
usually teach at this time on tuesdays
and I requested the sake of you here me
and my mother and my daughter and some
good friends anyway so welcome everybody
i'm going to i wish that that we had
time but we're too big a room to do the
exercise that i did with the world
history students in the smaller group
just before this meeting where i asked
each of them to think about the history
the background of their name
who gave them the name what's the
cultural significance of do you have a
nickname how do you feel about your name
because it's a wonderful way for us to
all get to know each other but we
unfortunately don't have time to do that
tonight so just think about it as we
proceed because we're going to be
talking about someone story and we're
going to start with this person's name
I'm going to get you going right away on
on an exercise and because I'm drawing
material from both oral history and
social work I hope those of you who are
here from both disciplines will get
something from this exercise I'm going
to pose a question first and and then
I'm going to describe to you what we're
all going to do as a group the artists
are Ian Donald Richie in the book doing
oral history a practical guide asked the
question should the interviewer be an
objective or neutral observer and given
tonight's topic I think my question to
you is cat the interviewer be neutral or
objective observer in the past we really
i think in oral history and in social
work there was kind of the feeling that
we should come to the cut to come to the
table as a sort of a blank slate that we
really shouldn't bring with us our
biases and prejudices that we should
leave them at home because they might in
some way influence the course of the
work be it an oral history interview or
an interview in a therapy session but
what I'm really going to focus on
tonight is the fact that we do bring
these with
us that we carry them with us that we
have long traditions of cultural legacy
that we do with us and that if we can
learn to become self-aware and to
utilize this material it it can really
help us in our work whichever discipline
where we're working in or in both as i
am and later on I'm going to talk a
little bit about the convergences and
divergences of oral history in therapy
and what it means to be working in one
discipline with the background in
another and vice versa so at looking at
that question you know can the
interviewer be objectively neutral what
I'm going to do is I'm going to tell you
a story and this is a story of a client
that I worked with and when I say client
for those of you who are not coming from
mental health field this is what we call
patients now mental health clinics not
in hospitals they're slow patients but
in an attempt to kind of equalize the
balance between the worker and and the
individual who use the word client I'm
going to tell you this woman's story
this is a woman I worked with many many
years ago and I'm not going to tell you
anything about her ethnicity and I'm
going to stop every couple of sentences
and I'm going to ask you to tell me what
you're thinking just given what I'm what
I'm relating to you so I'd like to start
with her name her name is Gloria so take
a minute to think about somebody named
Gloria and what comes to mind just don't
then raise your hands my mom your mom
okay anyone else have associations with
the name Gloria that might be different
then it's another poem
okay tell you the back is why leave it
so leave some far we have well the least
you don't it doesn't was not since
you're thinking of her mother okay they
have three people three people who have
have given us you know well the two of
you have the same view okay two people
giving us given us completely different
views of no I don't know anything about
your mother so I have no idea what her
background is but an italian-american in
the fifties anyone else have associated
with the name Gloria gives me an age
reference it's not as being the shoes
young people passed away today so I
think of somebody okay so we'll start
with that so already just these few
hands that went up we have we have some
context perhaps some cultural context
but we really don't know what it is
Gloria is actually 56 and she's the hub
of a bustling family which has survived
many tragedies so any thoughts about
Gloria she's the hub of a bustling
family any ideas about what this family
might might be like what that means to
be the hub of a bustling family
and thoughts about that yeah Disney
productive family okay going to school
yes
okay so a picture of what a bustling
family my name any other ideas maybe
she's not married interesting yeah I
thought it was interesting that someone
here mentioned parents because you know
coming from a single family household
when I think of like a bustling family
it's just I think of my mom so like in
my mind Gloria was the single mother so
well just think of this is some kind of
a tapestry of leaving with all these
different possibilities Gloria's husband
who had begun suffering seizures after a
head injury incurred while on active
duty sorry Gloria's husband had begun
suffering seizures after a head injury
incurred while on active duty in Vietnam
okay so this tells us something about
the historical context Gloria's husband
so it turns out for it has a husband and
he was in Vietnam any thoughts about
what this might mean
it certainly places Gloria's husband in
some kind of historical context any and
the political content and the quantity
nom right open lower middle class okay
so looks like maybe the family's lower
middle class yeah it's blurry medium
caregiver or even a caregiver position
yeah
so already I feel like we're leaving
this story out of these couple of
sentences he was able to go back to work
when we came after after the war came
back to this country but he was
subsequently disabled in a work-related
accident nearly 30 years ago Gloria had
to become both mother and father to
their three children so I think you
mentioned fair killer she she now is a
caregiver Gloria grew up in New York
City the third of four daughters her
father was a hard-working man who valued
education for his daughters so what
might that tell us about the family
immigrant family anybody else think this
might be an immigrant family and if so
why what makes you say value
and particularly for his daughters I
tell you something
okay Laura did well in school and won a
scholarship to a state college but
disappointed her father by turning it
down and getting a secretarial job in a
bank Oh what's about that
strong headed she was willing to be
non-compliant might there be other
reasons why she turned down going to
college and got a job yeah it could have
been married at that point possible okay
other dance a lil more generally like
like Intel obligation okay so if we're
looking at an immigrant family maybe
this with a little class family maybe
she was expected in some work way to
contribute to the household we we don't
know yet any other thoughts about why
my own mother that was a mirror
as many years later
she went to college I think it had very
much to do
so we may be dealing with gender issues
here as well well we're about to find
out Gloria had set set her sights on
marriage and family and this seemed the
quickest way to achieve her goal so this
is why Gloria turned down a scholarship
Gloria married a man like her father
industrious but constrained in his
capacity to show love her husband and
only child had grown up without a father
and had no male role model in his life
any ideas about his family Gloria
listen
when Gloria's husband had the accident
everything changed he was in a coma for
six months and when he emerged he was a
different person docile and childlike
their son who was eight years old at the
time became angry and confused Gloria
saw it held for the family so we're
starting to create a picture of warrior
what does this tell you we don't know
what kind of help she saw but
so depending what kind of help she saw
cultural expectation
like mental health services or
supporting so funny we don't know we
don't know whether she went to her
church whether she went to a therapist
week that we don't know but but her from
reaching out for help just tell us
something about about Gloria because
Luria's husband could no longer work she
had to become the breadwinner
fortunately her mother lived nearby and
was able to help with the three young
children any thoughts about that we know
Gloria's mother who's available to
attend without the kids she's not living
with dad right slurping right dad can't
I mean he's not an in condition to take
care of the kids
does anybody getting a picture in your
minds of what what this family might be
like what the socio-economic
circumstances the ethnicity
what I want you to do is to really kind
of think about what's going on in terms
of your awareness as you listen to the
story what kind of picture is coming to
mind based on your assumptions your
expectations your understanding of the
era in which you grew up etc okay work
became glorious salvation she began to
take an interest in her career and rose
up the corporate ladder to become a vice
president at one of the largest
financial institutions in New York City
in the 1980s she was given award an
award for her achievements so now what
are you thinking about Gloria
you come from The Wall Street best
financial institution she'd probably
earned a lot of money on that hat and
thinking about being a woman in you know
in a large financial institutions like
probably pretty tough customer and in
the night in the 1980s and any thoughts
about her in terms of her ethnicity at
this point if anything that you would
rule out she said as I recognize anyone
else thinking she sounds Irish though
yep she all of a sudden became white to
me she became like I had this picture of
a woman of color and then after your
last statement she became was anybody
else thinking that yeah
okay so let's go on as glorious children
reached adulthood she had to face a
reality that was difficult for her both
her daughters were married and had
children but her son was gay it took her
some time to accept however she adored
her son and embraced his lover as one of
the family anybody else thinks something
different at this point
so now we might be picturing and holding
his Irish Catholics the hub of a large
family let's see what happens this is
where some of the really worst tragedies
of her life begin Gloria's son developed
some health problems and she denied her
and remember this was this when I wrote
this is was at it at a time where we're
having having a diagnosis of AIDS was a
death sentence she denied to herself
what she knew to be true her son's lover
had died of AIDS her son was affected as
well and Gloria really really was was
angry at herself that she had not paid
attention to his his developing illness
I think inside she knew what was going
on and she felt somehow she could have
had she attended to this earlier she
could have she could have done something
different when I'm when I give the
chronology now it's when I wrote this
particular story I was actually still
working with Gloria and I will give you
followed then we're going to meet her on
camera at the end of this she's going to
come through the door actually she
almost did because I have not spoken to
Gloria in 10 years and I called her when
I knew I was going to be giving his
workshop she doesn't live in New York
anymore and she would love to have been
able to be here because anyway so two
years ago in this chronology Gloria
developed a respiratory infection and
that landed her in the hospital she was
under great stress at work and did not
take care of herself when she became ill
what's is telling us so here's this
woman taking care of her whole family
yeah
she's a workaholic and what what else is
she what is what is she not doing here
she's not taking care of herself she's
taking care of everyone else but she's
not taking care of herself the infection
affected her heart and she had to have
open heart surgery a pacemaker was
implanted just in parentheses when I
show you the film which was actually
made as it part of a teaching field for
the Social Work school here at Columbia
the cameramen from the center for new
media was hiking Gloria and he kept
picking up a Spanish radio station and
he was running all over the building
trying to figure out where this was
coming from and it turns out her
pacemaker was acting as a transmitter so
the two weeks after Gloria came home
from the hospital her husband had a
stroke their son had taken care of his
father while Maria was in the hospital
and he was now taken care of Gloria but
he was not feeling well either and two
weeks later he died so this is a family
with multiple multiple layers of tragedy
at this point Gloria had become quite
depressed understand
and she was referred by the visiting
nurse service for therapy at the clinic
where I work the past two years has been
a journey of grief and recovery for
Gloria and her family when she first
came for help she was in such pain that
she could tolerate only an occasional
session she was often unable to leave
the house for days at a time but after a
while Gloria began to sense that the
treatment was helping her and she made
the effort to get to her sessions the
whole family pulled together to help
Gloria out of her depression she was the
center of their universe so what are we
seeing now in terms of Gloria and her
life and her family
but they're they're really rallying
around her and they recognize that they
can't let her they can't let her sink
into a depression occasionally Gloria
brought a member of her family with me
when she came to see me over time I met
both of her daughters her husband and
even her 9 year old grandson and in the
clinic where I work having children come
into the sessions is not something we
usually do but I felt it was important
given the family circumstances to have
her grandson come in and I gave him some
things to play with on the floor and at
a certain point I turned to him and I
said to him do you miss your uncle and
he said yes because he was very close to
the uncle and at that point I said will
you know your grandma is here because it
can help to talk to somebody and you
know I just did it I included him in the
in the session and then actually he
talked about a sample and I think that
was I think that was helpful for him
because my sense was that the family was
really rallying around Gloria and then
everybody else was kind of having to
fend for themselves at first Gloria felt
guilty but as we when she began glory
began to laugh again after after a
period of time she began to be able to
laugh again and at first she felt guilty
but as we explored her grief she was
able to express her loving enjoys
feelings as well Gloria and her family
decided that they needed to be
the new phase of their lives and Gloria
accepted a generous retirement package
from her job and her family bought a
large piece of property in Pennsylvania
where they built homes Gloria and her
husband and their older daughter and
family who lived with Gloria's mother
and the younger daughter action was a
Social Work school and married and had a
young child and was ready to build yet
but they had a place where that family
when family wanted to join them her at a
certain point and so they moved to
Pennsylvania and then Gloria took
custody of her 15 year aneesa's 15 year
old son this boy's mother had just been
released from prison and his father left
when he was a baby Gloria wanted to give
him the opportunity to grow up in a warm
and loving family so what what's
everybody thinking now so here she is
they've started this new phase of their
lives and and now she's taking custody
of her 15 year old her nieces 15 year
old son and she wants to give him
because I mean just by land
the
they're very superior
and and perhaps also having lost your
own son opportunity to intimate take
care of her as well a few months ago
warrior got up during the night and
tripped on the family cat she broke her
leg and had to have surgery followed by
several weeks of rehabilitation she's
walking with a walker and you need to be
fitted with a brace but she has come
through the experience with a
determination not to let her let it pull
her back into a depression and I'm not
going to tell you the last sentence of
this because I'm gonna let Gloria speak
for herself so what I'd like all of you
to do is to try and create a mental
picture of Gloria and I'm going to tell
you a little bit about the interview
that I did with her this was an
interview that I did before I before
there ever was a little history program
here at Columbia and I was doing it as
part of a teaching film that i made from
the Social Work school and in this film
it was it's a film actually on aging and
sexuality but there was one segment and
that is Gloria's story that really
didn't have much to do with sexuality
she didn't talk about sexuality except
when I asked her specific pointed
questions because that was the topic of
the film and I really needed to ask her
something about sexuality whereas the
other people in the film talked very
very openly in fact I think the 30 years
some odd year old camera man's eyes were
popping out of his head because he may
be somewhat your old woman was talking
about her sex life but but when the film
was put together this the Social Work
school really the committee really felt
that we should take this segment out and
put it into a segment that had to do
with culture and learning about
and I said no this really is how this
woman talks about herself in terms of
her sexuality she talks about it in
terms of her being a woman and what it
means to going to be a woman in her
culture and so they left it in and I'm
very glad they did so I'm going to
introduce you to Gloria but I really
want you to just think about what your
assumptions are and when we listen to
the interview what I want you to do is
to think about certain themes that come
up cultural themes historical themes
you'll see that there's a tremendous
emphasis in what she says on appearance
and what appearance means to her and why
it's important for her to why it's so
important to present yourself in a
certain way now is true she worked in
the corporate world and you know we
probably attest to the fact that
presentation is extremely important but
there's a but but there's a little p
there's a historical key in this
interview and I want you to see if you
can pick it up and figure out what it is
historically that might make this focus
on appearance so important to Gloria and
I also just want to point out that was
10 years younger when I made his film
and it's hard for me to watch it what I
what I was going to say about about the
appearance is that at a certain point
Gloria talks about the fact that her
grandmother picked cotton but when she
went to church on Sunday she always made
sure that they had as Gloria said a
starched hanky and white gloves
and to me this was one of the keys in
the interview of the historical context
for the importance of appearance in
Gloria's life so if we're thinking about
about bringing culture to the table what
what would it mean to pick up a cue like
that in an interview what would the
importance of this little this little
moments that she talked about her
grandmother because if you didn't hear
that when she talks about getting her
nails done and going shopping with her
daughters you might think that this is a
woman who is looking at the
superficialities of appearance and what
it means but but how would you interpret
this this meaning of her of this what
she said about her grandmother
not just like how you present yourself
like
appearance-wise but also like how you
I think poorly but i also think if we
look at this sort of historical it's a
man howso say in terms of sort of trying
to garner that respects at being a woman
of color being people of color
especially back then you're trying to
sort of set yourself above what is
thought of you and so like a now we
always be well-dressed being needs being
part of being above I've what just and I
think if we can look at that that you
know theme in terms of cultural
historical team and what the what's that
what that meant to Gloria and also given
the chaos in her life and the multiple
layers of tragedy what it meant to her
to keep it together as we were saying
and to present an exterior that was that
was you know a cut above is as he said
to the rest of the world and it's one of
the sort of cues that we pick up in an
interview whether it's an oral history
interview or an interview in therapy or
in social work and and that is the the
body language the presentation so if we
take a story like Gloria's and we start
to analyze it from the point of view of
culture and this is where I'm going to
go back to my powerpoint
big fan of PowerPoint because there's
certain things that I just want to show
you I want to start out and my social
work students already heard me talk
about this but I want to talk about
belief systems because I think this is
an important thing to know somebody want
to do what yeah we can leave lights on
something in order to understand where
somebody is coming from in an interview
it's really important for us to think
about about the the kind of template of
belief system I think actually better
with the light on I'm sorry I think you
better with the light on so I can see
you if I I need to interact I'm going to
give you a kind of a template of our
belief systems and this isn't a hard and
fast sort of template there's a lot of
mouse over but it's it's a place to
start and if you think about belief
systems the way you would think about
the strength of the ripples when you
throw a stone into a pond the strongest
most core beliefs are at the center and
those are what are called our primitive
or core beliefs and primitive not in any
negative sense but primitive because
they're so fundamental to who we are any
thoughts about what might be examples of
our core or primitive beliefs and if we
change something in the primitive belief
system we shake up the whole system
profoundly
no that's coming next that's coming next
okay with that people care about each
other that would be a weena it would be
nice if that were worth quite a bit of a
Medical Corps bleep it's something like
I am a man I am a woman this is a the
sky is blue wherever you go in the world
and is interesting i've been reading a
book recently called through the
language glass that has to do with how
language affects our view of the world
and in Homer's time the description of
the sky was not as blue but it was wine
colored and is that because people saw
it differently or because the language
was different and analyzing it looks as
though the language is different which
make sense to us now but earlier when
there were analyses of Homer there was
this idea that maybe somehow people had
inherited the capacity to see who yet
and so because there wasn't much blue
other than the sky in homers time that
people will see because blue is it is a
color as a dying that came much later
historically and if you think about it
what is blue in nature occasionally a
flower but we don't see much that's blue
that's not artificial however now our
understanding is that the understanding
of color and that the sky is blue is one
of our core or fundamental beliefs if
you think about something like ones ones
ones identification as male or female
for example if you change this you will
shake up the whole system for somebody
who feels that they are born in and do
in a different body and the body that
isn't consistent with how they feel
inside or what happens when you get old
and the body that you've lived with all
these years or you become disabled the
body you've lived with all these years
suddenly betrays you you're your
fundamental sense of yourself and your
core belief is going to change it's
going to change the whole the whole
system if we move on to the next layer
and remember think again of this as the
ripples in a pond they get weaker as we
go further away or less less important
peripheral beliefs our peripheral belief
system is our system of beliefs that are
derived from authority figures so
somebody mentioned religion that's a
good example of beliefs derived
Authority what are some where do we
learn these these purple goals parents
families from our culture from authority
figures if we change something in the
peripheral belief system yes it will
shake the system but it's not going to
shake it as profoundly as if we change
something in the core belief system and
then we move on to the last layer which
is the income scheduling system and
inconsequential not because they don't
have any value or meaning but
inconsequential because this is the
system of beliefs that has to do with
our personal taste and whether you eat
this breakfast cereal or that breakfast
cereal you know unless there's something
circumstantial that that that changes is
not really going to make much difference
in terms of the belief systems on which
your your culture is is founded and if
you think about it developmentally
what's the time of life where the
inconsequential beliefs are changing
from second to second
I mean I always think of one of my one
of my kids whose teacher said all of the
nonconformists go to the side of the
room in middle school and all of the
conformers going to design the whole
class went to the nonconformist side so
keep this in mind as a template again it
doesn't it's not a you know which for
purposes of a PowerPoint I had to draw
it as distinct belief systems of course
there's there's some some crossover
between them and in one interesting
thing about belief systems there was a
writer of psychologist who wrote a book
of his name is Milton world each some of
you may have heard of him and he wrote a
book called its pre-crisis of ypsilanti
and Ypsilanti Michigan there was a
mental hospital there he went and he
lived for a couple of years as a
participant observer in this mental
hospital epsilon T and a very common
delusion among men who are mentally ill
is that they are Jesus Christ and he had
a group of men all of whom claim to be
Jesus Christ and he followed them over
the course of a period of a couple of
years and a lot of the men dropped out
of the group but story remained and
hence the three Christ of ypsilanti and
in in his descriptions and transcripts
of their of their discussions one of the
things that emerged was a fundamental
belief and that is that no matter how
delusional these men were they knew that
that each of them was I they knew that
each of them was I and not you and and
and that there was a certain value in
being I one of the men said well you
can't be Jesus Christ because you know
I'm Jesus Christ but he knew that that
he couldn't be this other person and
that was a part of his fundamental
system in order also to think about and
understand our cultural beliefs and how
they impact our work and those of you
who have a psychology background may be
familiar with the five-factor model of
personality in the five-factor model of
personality researchers looked at
personality traits all over the world in
all kinds of cultures and all kinds of
enormous enormous study of personality
and what was discovered was that there
were five major factors that occurred in
every society in every culture they may
have been expressed differently but that
they were present in terms of our
understanding of another human being and
another human beings behavior and way of
relating to us and you can remember them
with the word ocean openness and again
each of these is a continuum so it's not
like somebody is open or closed but
there's a degree of openness and we
understand it within a cultural context
and we understand it we also understand
it within the circumstances so I may be
very open with my with my best friends
but I may be less open let's say in a
work in a work setting for example and
how does that impact our work this is a
this is certainly a question that social
work students grapple with all the time
how much of myself do I share with my
clients and this came up in the
discussion with the world history
students as well you know what what what
do I do how much do I say in an oral
history interview conscientiousness we
in our society certain value a high
degree of conscientiousness extraversion
is interesting because how we interpret
that in terms of our culture whether we
make eye contact whether
considered disrespectful to make eye
contact whether a high degree of
extraversion is prized in it in a
society or not is something that we need
to to understand when we're doing an
interview agreeableness is something I
think certainly all of us value a high
degree of agreeableness and here
neuroticism which is kind of a were this
out of date these days really means
level of anxiety so I wanted to talk a
little bit about parallels between
therapy and oral history because I'm
really enjoying for both disciplines
since I have experience in both those
backgrounds there was a there has been
an effort in in in therapy driven by a
group of women who found an
institutional home at Wellesley College
called the stone Center for Research on
women to try and formulate a kind of
therapy that come to be called the
Malaysian cultural model of therapy and
this very much parallel some of the
emphasis in oral history on
intersubjectivity and what it really
means is the meeting space between the
interviewee and the interviewer or
between the client and the worker is
where the word takes place whereas in
the past there was an attempt to kind of
sanitize the the experience and the idea
that either the interviewer or the
therapist should come to the table and
and kind of have the upper hand in the
sense and and what's going on in both
fields now fortunately is moving in the
direction of a kind of an equalization
which doesn't mean that you don't bring
your professional expertise but in it
what it means is that that it's a
dialogue and that a lot of this dialogue
takes place through stories so Jean
Baker Miller who was one of the founders
of the stone center
talks about what she calls the five good
things the first one being zest and if
we think about Gloria how do we how do
we where do we find the place resist in
her life does she seem like somebody who
has a high degree of zest I think we
would all agree that she does and I wish
we could get to meet her but clarity
clarity meaning in terms of how we do a
situation that were able to do a
situation with an understanding of what
what the ramifications what the
background is sense of self-worth
obviously I think pretty
self-explanatory creativity and
productivity and a desire for more
connection and connection is something
that is a critical critical word in both
the interview process in oral history
and in therapy and I think that that if
I focus on the idea of connection and we
think about what the interview brings us
it is a sense of connection and that's
what we're really striving for if we're
looking to analyze a story we look at it
from the point of view of the structure
of the story from the point of view of
the socio cultural influences of a story
the interpersonal aspects and the
personal as well and what's interesting
in terms of how we learn this how we how
we learn to communicate within our
culture from the moment a child can
understand the spoken word his parents
begin to speak to him or her from a
common past often going back several
generations so I couldn't
a picture of my granddaughter in there
she's now two and a half and she talks
up a storm but even here at this young
age when she wasn't really talking you
can see the she is already beginning to
understand the spoken word and the way
we communicate if i say to you once upon
a time those of you who were born here
and grew up speaking English what what
what does it bring to mind a fairy a
fairy tale how do we know how do we know
that once upon a time is that we mean a
fairy tale they all begin that way and
and what do you think of when you hear
once upon a time what what what what
kind of context do you imagine yourself
in what Disney movie Disney movies
that's interesting yeah happiness like a
time that's not existed sorry the
timeless quality
childhood
something that ends happily so just in
these few words you can see how much fur
for those of you who grew up with once
upon a time how much is in not even a
whole sentence and won't be what we
interpolate and what we bring in terms
of our understanding of the culture some
cultures reinforce the value of
storytelling and some don't and I think
one of the things that we've really lost
in in the United States in modern
culture is the value of storytelling I
when I was growing up my grandmother
told a lot of stories and I wish I have
listened more carefully but certainly as
as a therapist and as involve the story
and the story is really what what is the
essential to to my work and even if you
think about what it means when you go to
the doctor you tell the doctor a story
the doctor may turn it into a case or a
case study in her case history but in
fact you were telling a story and I know
Colombia has a narrative medicine
program now and Rita sharone was one of
the one of the founders of the the whole
field of narrative medicine I remember
hearing her tell a story about a man who
brought in his elderly father and the
father was having
call to you because he was having
trouble getting he was having trouble
with incontinence and in really taking
the time to talk to this this pair the
father and son what what she learned was
that the father's wheelchair was too big
to get through the bathroom door so he
couldn't get to the bathroom and had she
not taken the time to do that and just
simply written a prescription for our
medication for him it would have been a
whole different issue but because she
took the time to really listen to their
story she was able to help them if she
was able to help this older man retain
some of his dignity because that is one
of the areas that's the most of the hope
for people who are who are unable to to
go to the bathroom by themselves in in
creating a story we look at narrative
linkages and in narrative linkages what
what happens is that we assemble spheres
of meaning in the context of our life
form experiences so if we're looking at
understanding an oral history for
example or we're listening to a client
story we're really looking at the heat
at how that person assemble spheres
meaning but at the same time telling a
story as an act of creation and it's an
active selection and we're also creating
the story at the same time that we're
listening to it were also creating it
and every time we tell a story that
story is being told differently what's
very very important is what voices are
not heard and interestingly enough in
the film of Gloria she never mentions
her son and I think in some ways it was
partly because it was probably too raw
and she didn't
want to end up crying on the camera but
it's interesting that she talks joyously
about her whole family which she never
mentions him yet if you know her story
his story is one of us his voice is one
of the voices that is not heard and it's
important when you're listening to
somebody talk and tell their story to
really also think to yourself what
voices are not being heard in order to
really understand the meaning of the
story there are certain things that we
should focus on first of all is there a
theme song and by a theme song I mean
not only repeated images but something
that is meaningful for example in
Gloria's case I think the theme song
really had to do with keeping up
appearances and understanding that theme
song again in the historical context so
if you if you each took a moment to
think about your theme song today
because the theme song changes all the
time what would you what would you come
up with
I see a lot of people swarming around
everybody cares yeah anyone else but
think about it and occasionally check in
with yourself and say what's my theme
song today repeated images are very
important because repeated images are
our images that are meaningful to the
individual in the context of the story
working with older people some who have
whom have cognitive impairment there are
times when repeated images may signal
some kind of cognitive difficulty but at
the same time people retain those
repeated images even at times where the
memory is not so good so focusing on
repeated images what are the turning
points of the story certainly in
Gloria's life there have been many many
turning points but in critical turning
points hers when she had to go back to
work and that really that really changed
her whole life in many ways looking at
historical and cultural
already talked about is this very
reflective of a larger story sometimes
it is and sometimes it isn't but usually
it is usually it's reflective of a
larger story I also like to think about
the most surprised and the meaning of
paradox in a story a lot of times we'll
hear something that really is
paradoxical and we have to pay attention
to that yeah a lot of more about what
you mean by reflective of a larger story
well let me see if I can think of an
example remember with corridor um yes
Gloria that definitely I could say for
example that her her story is reflective
of a larger story not only the not only
the story let's say of the of the
history of what happened in in terms of
AIDS in terms of her son if we look at
it in the context of slavery and the
legacy of slavery those are two examples
I think of how her story is reflective
of the larger story
um one of our most important roles is to
bear witness and I want to tell you a
little bit about this and why I put the
picture of myself in here again this is
a 99 year old Hulk uh survivor she was
in several different concentration camps
managed to survive and I did a long
interview with her and it was
interesting during the interview she
just she wrote a book not too long
before I did this interview
unfortunately she's now suffering from
dementia but she wrote a book called
don't cry for me my sons and her sons
were hidden children during during the
war she was living in Poland when she
was deported and her sons were hidden
and the sculpture that you see in the
background is a sculpture that was done
by her sister and is it's a picture I
make it out they're coming out to
clearly there's it's it's a sculpture of
of a woman with a little boy and her
sister did it after she found this
woman's son and what was really amazing
was that in the interview and this was
an oral history interview in the
interview her son had set up the
interview
and he he said to me ask her to sing
even at 99 she has an amazing voice and
it turns out that after the war she had
become part of a porous the Yiddish
chorus she had moved to France and
become part of the chorus and she sang
for me three songs in Yiddish and when
she sang she was really transported back
to another time I mean it was quite
extraordinary this woman with a kind of
a shaking voice suddenly became this
young girl and she really didn't want to
focus in the interview on her her
experience in the camp she said to me
you can read about that in my book which
she wanted to talk about was her
childhood in Poland that were very very
poor but there was some wonderful things
and she wanted to share that with me and
really are our most important role is to
bear witness we can't change the
traumatic material but we can be there
for people did you agree I like this
quote each time I tell my story I
removed one small bit of heard from
inside the IDS my wound and I'm going to
share another story with you now a
series of all history interviews that
I've done actually with a client
got commissioned in front of the clinic
where I work to interview this woman and
we're also going to meet her the
students your mystery program just met
her but hopefully we'll be able to hear
her this time this is a woman who is now
96 an african-american woman her name is
marvelous without the E and she was
referred to our clinic because she had
become depressed because she would
really lost her independence she become
physically ill and she couldn't move
around anymore and she had she was
always used to being very independent
and taken care of herself and one of the
things that the clinic where I work does
is that we do home visits and so she
could not get out of bed and so I go to
her home every week and I do visits with
her he Alabama and he ended up working
as a houseboy for booker t washington
and north washington carver and they it
was just around the time that they were
found in Tuskegee for those of you who
are not familiar with Tuskegee it's it's
and it was the first University for
African Americans in the United States
and they encouraged him to they
encouraged him to to go to school and
and he was able to do that and he was in
one of the first graduating classes he
graduated in 1902 and he moved to Texas
and he founded the first technical
school for four black young men and
there's documentation of this and the
documentation was gotten buying
marvelous
much much difficulty she made three
trips to Texas and they would not let
her into the archive and finally she
found somebody who said well you should
go talk to so and so in the back room
and there was an african-american woman
working in the archive in the back room
who said to her I know where we can find
the record of this of this school and
actually gave it to her and there is
listening with her father's name and it
was called the Dallas Negro high school
anyway her father then had a series of
jobs he married he actually married one
of his one of his high school classmates
I think and he they moved to think they
well they moved around quite a bit cause
he had a number of teaching jobs and
unfortunately the marvelous was 14 who
died leaving his more mrs. mother with
seven children to support and she had
never worked and typical of many stories
like this she moved up north there was
an uncle or somebody a brother who put
them up to a little while and they moved
to two little bit more than Manhattan
and the only work she could get in his
day work or things are domestic and just
somehow she cobbled together a living
enough to put some food on the table but
they were very very poor and marvelous
and her sisters all got married when
they were very young or was married at
16 to relieve their mother of the burden
of taking care of them and also as
marvelous said there was always a danger
that you might get pregnant and that was
a terribly terribly shameful thing at
that time so marvelous married at 16 and
was not able marriage and towards the
end of the marriage her husband became
abusive and one night he kind of went
crazy and he held a knife to report and
it was a middle of winter and somehow
she managed to take her kids and go next
door to a neighbor's house and get away
and she ended up moving to first to the
Bronx because she had a sister naraku's
was managing a bar and she was able to
get a job working in the bar but then
the bar closed and she was left with no
source of income so she moved to New
York City and like the mother she she
got work as a domestic and she worked
three different jobs and there were
times where she had no food she wanted
her children to eat and she ended up
going to the hospital at one point to
the emergency room because she was so
weak and the doctor wanted to give her
something to stimulate her appetite and
she said no I don't want this because I
have
she she didn't want to have to have to
eat you wanted to put the food on the
table for her kids anyway over the years
gradually just with hard work and
persistence she managed to get a job in
a department store stamping in those
days they had metal charge cards and she
got a job doing that and she kind of
worked her way up and and ended up
getting a job as a switchboard operator
at an organization called the American
Jewish Committee and in the 1960s the
American Jewish Committee was very
involved in the civil rights movement
and they sent marvelous down south many
times with a delegation of some
prominent New Yorkers who are involved
in the civil rights movement and she was
involved in the march on Selma and I'm
going to show you some pictures from
that as well she risked her life many
times she worked closely with some of
our great civil rights leaders and she
worked there she worked with them for 30
years she became an office manager there
and every member of her family died of
cancer and she had breast cancer twice
and finally when she retired she ended
up volunteering her time for cancer
cares and personal kettering and she won
some awards for her volunteer work as
well and when she could no longer walk
she had to quit and that's the point of
which I started working with her i said
to her marvelous lure a little archive
she had all kinds of documents and
photographs of things like
that she had collected over the years
and I said you really should write your
story and she said well you know I my
family and my friends have told me as
many times but I don't have anything
really that unusual to talk about her to
say and I came back to my event
supervisor who subsequently not there
anymore he was able to think outside the
box and I said you know I wish I
couldn't record these ones was women's
stories they're so fascinating and she
said to me sign a release form go for it
and I did and I did 13 audio interviews
with her and then a filmed interview and
I said to her you know this material
should go to an archive unless your
daughters are interested in having it
and she checked with him and they said
they weren't particularly interested so
I said what if i were to contact the
archive of Tuskegee and see if they'd be
interested in having this well the
director of the archive called me back
and he practically jumped through the
phone he was so excited and they're in
the process now of transcribing the
interviews and they are they're going to
create what they that's sort of what
they call a digital file cabinet for her
in their archive and I've sent them now
with her permission we copied I copied
for her everything photographs and mold
that it's MP said the material to
Tuskegee and at a certain point she the
phone rang we were doing these
interviews
and it was her grandson who wanted to
tell her about a new job that he had
gotten and she said to him I can't talk
to you now I'm writing my book and it
was just it was so wonderful anyway
unfortunately about a month ago she was
hospitalized and she now has cancer
that's colon cancer that's metastasize
everywhere and she's dying and she knows
it and she wants to stay alive long
enough to see something come of this and
I'm not sure that she's going to but I
feel as though she knows that there's
this legacy and she knows that I'm
talking about her at columbia tonight I
saw her this morning and every time I
leave there now I don't know whether I'm
going to see her again and whenever I go
to see her I walk in as the social
worker I am her social Ibrahim prepared
always to begin with that but she now
wants to talk about her story and that's
really become what we do and it's really
good wonderful just a couple of quotes
that I want to share with you before I
show you the pictures and show you the
film over her the French philosopher
Simone Weil said the love of our
neighbor in all its fullness simply
means being able to say to him what are
you going through and I think that
that's in a sense well certainly
certainly as a therapist that's the most
important question we can ask I'm going
to talk a little bit about
how I key that is when we get into oral
history but the poet audre Lorde wrote
letters to her therapist and I think
this is something that really speaks to
both disciplines when she said one part
of my story is yours too so let me just
introduce you to marvelous
I hope that you'll be able to cure this
this is the clip
technical support here again oh here we
go maybe take it out
what has this process of telling the
story of it like for you
something that I never expected in my
life could happen to you and me this
epistle the bathroom because nobody else
has ever said listen to that we had to
ask questions and maybe I meant that
when I'm Congress or my panic comes I
just want to show you some of the
pictures of her that she shared with me
this is on the right there where it says
OD theory I'll be black interior that's
Marcus's father
actually it says OD ended on the top
earlier that's her brother who was a
student at the school this is marvelous
with her husband
and
marvelous is on the first row on the
lower right she belonged to a she belong
to a group most of these are sisters and
cousins and they used to get dressed up
and go dancing here are just some
pictures from her her life that actually
is her mother on the upper left and
these are marvelous investor Marcus
various times in her life
here is the march on Selma marvelously
far left and one of the things that was
quite incredible when she talked about
this story was that when they came to
leave after the march first of all she
had to ride on the floor of the car
because just a couple days before that a
white woman had been killed riding in
the car with a group of black men and
her life would have been in danger had
she been the only black person in a car
full of white people but when it came
time to leave the airline to the
staircase away so they couldn't get on
the plane because she was with them and
they actually ended up having to take a
bus i think to atlanta where they were
able to take a plane so i wanted to
share that with you and then
here
this was marvelous at 92 when she was
still up and running around in fact she
she told me that when she was I guess
she was about ninety two or three she
rented a car and she drove all the way
from Massachusetts to South Carolina to
visit some relatives quite a character
anyway I'm sorry to keep doing this with
the lights when somebody could get the
once again so we don't have much time
left but I just I just wanted to talk a
little bit about the the intersection of
history and therapy and also the places
where they diverge when I was the kid
there was a toy that I had it was a
cardboard and on one side it was a sort
of a simple electronic thing on one side
there were a list of capitals and on the
other side there were list of the states
and there was like a circuit board on
the back with a little red light and two
electrodes and if you've got the state
and the capital if they matched up a
light would light up and we get a point
and I often thought of this when I first
went to Social Work school many years
ago because in my days as a Social Work
student there seemed to be these phrases
that I kind of plug in when I was
working with clients like that must be
very difficult for you
and it reminded me of that circuit board
and most of the time the light lit up
and people really felt understood I did
have one client who was a feisty woman
who had been a social worker herself and
when I tried that she said don't give me
that social worker talk but most of it's
hard when I said to people that must be
very hard for you or you must have been
through a lot I got this response from
people like wow you're really listening
to me really under understanding what
I'm saying where does that come in
though in the oil history interview and
when I met with the with the orchestra
students just before our meeting tonight
this is one of the questions what do you
say what do you do when somebody's
talking about traumatic material this is
really a workshop for a whole other time
and I don't have time to really go into
it now but one of the things that I've
had to learn working these two
disciplines is that there are a lot of
points of connection but there are also
times where I really have to sit on my
hands because when I'm working as a
therapist I have the luxury of saying to
somebody you know I noticed when you
were talking about your abusive husband
you had a big smile on your face can you
tell me what's going on behind the smile
i can stop people and i can say to them
what's happening right now what's going
on between us that's a kind of a luxury
that you don't have
history interview in oral history
interview sometimes you just have to sit
there and let this painful material
happen at the same time when I'm working
as a therapist I have to be careful
because I do use a lot of narrative in
my work I have to be careful that I
don't allow myself to get derailed by
the story and not necessarily address
some important issues like housing or
medications or things that are going on
right now with this with this particular
client because I can really get lost in
the story in fact i came across a little
report card from my preschool days and
it said that when i entered the girl in
the morning and said I i bounce in with
my cheerful you know what and proceeded
to launch it to a story so I guess
there's a history there her community
but but I have to be careful again that
I don't get derailed by the story and
just an example of that is is a client
that I worked with who was i worked with
her a night she left and she's just come
back and i had one session with her
after several years of not seeing her
and she's an african-american woman a
marxist feminist writer and she had gone
to a Marxist feminist therapist for many
many years and what had happened is that
she wasn't getting any better and it
turned out she had undiagnosed bipolar
disorder and nobody was paying attention
to that because they really were looking
at the cultural and historical and
oppressive factors that she had
realistically had been living with all
of her life and at the same time there
was this issue that wasn't being
addressed and when she had a psychiatric
assessment and was discovered that she
had this on diagnosed bipolar disorder
she was put on appropriate medication
she was really able to to start moving
forward and when she came to me she came
to me with a grid that she called
personal Renaissance and in the grid
were the areas that she wanted to
address and and I asked her where she
wanted to begin and she wanted to begin
with her health and the fact that she
had not really been taken care of it but
but I have to be careful in a situation
like that that I didn't get lost in the
story that I really also pay attention
to to the therapeutic aspects and yet
over and over and over again I've seen
the therapeutic value of narrative
whether it's an oral history or whether
it's in therapy and and what I really
would would like to see some day is a
study of people who have been depressed
for example whom if you tell their
stories and weather this has a lasting
effect so
we do this we're just beginning to
really in the field in the mental health
field really appreciate the value of
narrative in terms of evidence-based
practice at this point so any more sort
of coming to the end of the time but I
want to leave time for questions and
answers flexions questions
larger than your wife
receiving it but may have become
embellished over time I think stories do
and I think our job is never to try and
get the person to see the real story so
to speak as we might perceive it but I
think that I think that our job is
really to think about the disconnect
that there might be between the story
and if we know what the facts are and to
understand what the meaning of that
embellishment base for that individual
it's something it's something again as a
large area as a therapist I can address
you know the meaning of this but as an
oral historian we just make note of it
and and it may tell us something about
that individual women and about the
meaning of that story driven person
how do you
that's a that's a sort of Perpetual
question that comes up all the time and
and it comes up in both fields and it's
something that that you really have to
do I mean it's a case-by-case basis but
you have to really assess in each point
is this in the service of the other
individual or is it something that's in
the service of oneself and I've made the
mistakes sometimes of sharing things
about myself that another person had
absolutely no interest in and I'm also
I've also found that there were points
of connection in both areas I mean I as
part of a when I was in the oral history
program here as part of the program we
were taken to a to a sort of a post
prison residential Center treatment
center for four women and it so happened
that one of the guest speakers I had had
in my class was somebody who have been
in prison and when it turned out this
prisoner I entered this former prisoner
I interviewed had been in the same
prison as the woman who would come speak
in my class I I was bursting to tell you
know say something about this prison and
it turned out to be a wonderful point of
connection but it could be a disaster I
mean you know when she found out who it
was she said I loved her she says she
was wonderful you know and all of that
she said I never really got to know her
suddenly it gave me a sort of a
getting me kind of impressed with her
but I think on some level I may have
been doing it because I felt and I was
you know sort of new at this at that
point but I felt somehow that there's
this disconnect between us and how was I
supposed to connect with this woman and
it worked but it was risky and I think
had I not had these years and years of
experience as a therapist I might not
suggest doing something like that but
there have been times where I've shared
some some things with clients and
interviewers and has been it's really
it's been a wonderful point of
connection but again it requires in
either discipline and I continuous sort
of work self-reflection you have to be
analyzing yourself and working on
yourself at the same time and that goes
for the whole issue of the biases and
prejudices that we bring to our work as
well I know that's not a very concrete
answer but I think that if I could say
one thing it's really asking yourself is
this in the service of the other person
or am I doing this for some conscious or
unconscious self-serving reason
I shot a question is you mentioned
before mr.
someone was recounting a traumatic
experience
what what services are in face like
that's done or is that it I keep your
sleep in person yeah that's something
that came up in our earlier discussion
well here's when you end an interview
and someone is clearly visibly
distressed one of the things is an oral
historian that you can do is just simply
offer to speak to the person after the
interview let them have some time and
say can make yourself available
that's what I do you know for the next
couple days i prioritize their emails or
messages and spend some time thinking
until let them know yes indeed I did
hear that this was a very painful story
and most of the time what they're
looking for is that infect you or what
they and that's usually the end of that
and as an oral historian of course we're
not doing therapy so we need to be
really mindful fact that if someone
tells you something what steps can you
take you know and what steps do you need
to do it every once in a while there is
a situation where you encounter someone
waiting you might get to suggest
especially if it's a long-term
relationship that they might see you
know professional but that's that is not
the more but you certainly do not stupid
and I think that only for the persons
being interviewed but also for the
interviewer I mean the whole issue of
vicarious traumatization and I know
Columbia Columbia is done a huge 911
post-911 project and they actually ended
up hiring a team of psychologists for
the interviewers because some of them
were really traumatized by what they
were hearing in the interview so it's
just something something to be aware of
and it is one of the dangers of history
and says yeah
that we are
so how much I was listening to narrator
all time oh wait a minute is that my
stuff house and I'm not being that other
person and recording it that sort of
this is about trying to
Who I am in writing why am I
my stuff
you know how how would you ever think
how do you well I think certainly if
you're writing being self reflective is
informative for people who are reading
what you're writing in terms of what's
going on and the sort of parallel
process that might be going on during
the interview I mean I wouldn't
necessarily share this with with
somebody I'm doing in oral history with
in therapy I I might and in fact often
if I have let's say if it's a person of
color I might say to that person right
up front how do you feel about having a
white therapist and and I've done this
many times and I've generally gotten a
positive response for having asked the
question I don't know always and they're
always going to be differences between
you and the person you're interviewing
and those differences you know we can't
erase whom we are but we can be aware of
what the implications of our own culture
may mean to another person but the fact
that a person is agreeing to give an
oral history generally means that person
wants to tell his or her story and it
usually means that they are appreciating
the fact that they're being heard and I
think again that that the gift of of
listening to somebody true
speak to somebody which when we're
interviewing we're doing in fact I find
that the concentration required for an
oral history interview is is much more
intense than what's required in a
therapy session where I can stop and
interrupt and there's a bit back and
forth and you know people ask me
questions and that kind of thing whereas
in the oral history interview you're
really picking up the threads all the
time and but there are times when I when
I really tried to become I've become
aware of the fact that I was I was
feeling a certain way because of
something somebody was saying and not
just in terms of traumatic material
somebody who might have been presenting
something that I found admirable and I
thought oh if only I could have done
that or you know something of that sort
as well
okay well thank you everybody I had one
thing my mother who's sitting at the end
of the table there I interviewed her and
that was the hardest interview I've ever
done and when she was done she said I
hope my grandchildren don't think
you